- This nigga got weed,
he got stem weeds right here, nigga.
Oh, you really made my day.
I ain't lying.
Put that shit in the pillowcase, dawg.
So you gonna roll with me now.
This is how this nigga wanna talk.
"Man, I'm rolling with you
now, dawg, I apologize."
I don't wanna hear that sissy shit, nigga.
Put all that shit up, nigga.
I'll figure out if I'm
a give you some, nigga,
or not, nigga, 'cause
you ain't getting shit
right now, nigga.
Put all that, hey, homie.
Man, you got some nice colognes up here
on the dresser, man.
And I'm know I'm gonna
be wrong for taking this
from you, man, but Lord knows
I gotta have all that.
Y'all put all that in the bag.
This nigga started crying, dawg.
He straight up started crying.
I'm like looking at
this, what the fuck wrong
with you, dawg?
Man, I ain't giving y'all shit, nigga.
You should have just
gave us our little paper,
little money, nigga, and we woulda
been outta here, nigga.
I'm taking all this, nigga.
And if you get up and try
and do something, nigga,
I'm a kill your punk ass, nigga.
I swear to God, nigga, you better not
get your bitch ass up, nigga.
I'm a kill you, nigga.
Come on, nigga, bag the
rest of that shit up, nigga.
You sit down over there, homeboy.
Get your punk ass over there, nigga.
That's what you niggas gonna get, nigga,
and next time nigga tell
y'all motherfucking asses
to kick down, you gonna kick down, nigga.
Or you gonna lose out more
than what you want, nigga.
And you might lose your life, nigga.
Punk ass, nigga.
And especially dude, y'all,
I should just, blood,
I should just hit you in the stomach
with a bullet, nigga, just to show you
I ain't playing, punk.
Come on, man, get the
shit, nigga, let's go.
Make this punk ass nigga roll with me.
He supposed to be with
me, this nigga done turned
into a prune.
Goddamn prune, man, I swear to God, man.
I hate niggas that's a coward, man.
Tell you don't bring no gun,
old sissy ass, nigga.
Man we could get killed, nigga,
rolling in another nigga neighborhood.
Anyway, it went good.
Went back to my hood.
I kept mostly everything, dawg.
I think I gave that nigga like $50, dawg.
I kept everything, all
the weed, everything, CDs,
socks, cologne, I took
them nigga's clothes.
I took, man, some nice outfits.
That nigga had some nice
shit, man, I ain't lying.
I couldn't help myself, man.
Anyway.
That's another tough side
of my life, you know.
I'm changing, though,
man for the better, man.
And I only want people to, you know,
acknowledge the good side
of me and not the bad
and know that a person can change, man.
You just have to wanna change.
- [Mark] How'd you grow up?
- I grew up, man, in a neighborhood
where there was gangs, man.
I mean, and you can
wake up in the morning,
get ready to go to school,
body be laying in the trash can.
You'd be like, 'cause once you done told
your mother one time, shoot,
why tell her the second of the third time,
'cause it don't matter no more.
It's like just, oh, it's
just trash, you know.
So, my family didn't really look at it,
you know, we knew that we
was in a tough ass area
where, you know, they
didn't play games over here.
And I had to fight, man.
I grew up fighting
different dudes, you know,
so, I can be that person
that was acknowledged.
I hate to fight for my little brother
and my little brother had to fight
for the young one under him.
And I had an older brother,
which he had to fight for me
against other people
and my bigger brother had to fight,
man, it was like a train, I swear.
And if you seen some of the peoples
we fought in this neighborhood,
man, you'd be surprised.
My sister, we didn't even know nothing
about gangs just starting off, you know.
And my sister, I remember one time
she had a blue bandana on her head
and a dude snatched it off
her head and burned it.
I just looked at her, I was like,
you're too young to really
acknowledge, you know,
what happened, why he did
and nothing like that.
I really just didn't know.
I thought maybe he was
just mad at my sister,
just, you know, was snatching her hair
or something, you know.
We never knew the dude was, you know,
about colors and stuff.
And gradually as time went on, you know,
we was fighting for turf and colors.
You wear red, they wear blue, you know,
we was into each other.
I mean, I was going to
elementary getting high,
smoking on weed and shit like
that, you know, drinking.
And then gradually I started selling PCP.
I bought me some powder cocaine.
Started smoking powder cocaine, man,
and it was tough, man, because I thought
it was just, I thought it was cool, man.
Putting that shit all on my gums and shit,
you know, putting them
in cigarettes, you know.
We call them TCs, you know.
And as you see time, you know,
turn over and turn over,
'cause I was smoking powder cocaine
before I went to jail
and I did a robbery.
I did a little time.
I did like 3-1/2 years in Youth Authority.
And came out, my head was
like a big old vegetable.
You know, I thought I was
the baddest dude there,
and I'm ready to squabble with everybody,
let them know I'm here, you know.
But you can't run the neighborhood.
You can be a part of the foundation,
but you can't run the neighborhood.
Anyway, I started selling powder again.
Now when I get out, they got rocks.
And people was real, you know, real strict
on parents, certain parents
that were being, you know,
exposed to this type of drug.
'Cause if it was your mama,
you wouldn't want this homie of mine
to be selling your mother drugs.
So we was trying to keep
that real, you know,
limited on who you sell drugs to.
Slowly but surely it got outta hand
and people started being greedy
and not paying attention
to the real responsibilities
and the things that was more important.
We started doing the wrong things,
disrespecting, not respecting, you know,
all the people's other
parents, people's parents.
A lot of the dudes in the neighborhood,
and the females, too,
you know they ignored
the right thing, you know, and it got bad.
So they started selling
to people's mother.
Now the parents is
breaking down in the house.
You got no foundation
really standing good.
Everything's starting to crumble.
You wonder why there's
tears in a man's eye.
Because everything he
thought he was building good
turned into nothing but dust.
Later on as you look down the road,
here you are, using the same thing
that they was using and
trying to figure out
how to get off of it, what it would take
to leave it alone.
How strong did you need to
be in order to stop, man?
Mine's was bad.
My life was real tough.
I had to deal with a lot
of bullshit in the street.
I got shot a few times.
I done been beat across
the head with a board.
Nigga done accused me of doing the robbery
in they spot and I ain't robbed shit.
I done been told that
I took this from a man
and I ain't never even
seen this motherfucker.
Police done took me to jail
and jammed me with bullshit
and then you wanna know how much sanity
you can hold, man.
Walk this road straight.
Black man ain't really got too much,
you now, coming in this world,
so I mean, really,
dawg, my self was saying
I'll do everything I can
to fight this wickedness
up off of me.
Sometimes I feel like a demon or something
is walking behind me and is touching me.
But would you believe
me if I told you that?
Or would you think I was
just up here bullshitting?
I don't have no reason to bullshit.
I can bullshit myself down the road.
I got a lot of peoples
I could just talk to
on the sidelines.
I'd rather give it to you straight
so you ain't gotta talk about it no more
and just know that it was
something that existed.
A motherfucker living
this life out here, dawg.
And it's tough and it's real
and it's weary.
When I say that, look
behind you, goddamn me,
and wonder what the fuck just touched you,
'cause it wasn't me.
- [Mark] Did you have your dad?
- My pops died when I was a kid, man.
That's why I never really
experienced a father.
Me and my brothers, you know,
we used to deal with
my mother's boyfriend.
We didn't allow stepdaddies
in the house too tough, man.
You know, we knew that Mom
needed to get hers off,
you know, need to get her rocks off.
We didn't really know a
whole bunch about that,
but we know that there's
something in there
that she needed to do,
so we gave that respect to her.
But stepdads, my brothers, man,
they beat the stepdaddies up.
So we never really, one
time my brother told me,
he said, "SB, come let me in."
I was like, "Dawg, dude is downstairs."
"Man, just, nigga, come let me in."
Man, this nigga something else, man.
I go down here and let you in
and my mother's boyfriend fight,
he knocked the nigga out.
I don't even know the
nigga is knocked out, man.
I thought he was dead.
I said, "Aw, man."
He said, "SB, get the leg."
Man, I ain't getting his leg, shit.
Man, we drug this dude
and put him on somebody porch over there
and sat him up like he was sleeping
and I was saying shit, at least he look
all right, though, shit,
from that way, shit.
I went on back in the house.
I kept looking out the window
to see if he was all right.
Next minute I know, he was gone.
I was like shit.
Oh, man.
You know, from there it got real bad
because I said I know this nigga
gonna call my mother,
boy we in some trouble.
Shit, Dwayne the biggest,
so I figure she'd whoop
him first, you know.
I didn't get a chance to get a break.
She gonna have to whip him a long time.
He big and stuff, so my brother,
he was like all hilt up and stuff.
I'm like, shit, she gonna
whip him a long time, shoot.
She gonna wear herself out with him,
so I might get a little break.
So I said, "Mama, Dwayne told me to,
I didn't really do nothing, 'cause."
She was like, "Wait, just wait boy.
I'm a tell you about
what, let me talk to her."
I'm sitting here saying,
boy, it's gonna be tough
on me, man.
And she's saying "Ah, and he did what?
Huh?
No, he didn't.
And then what happened."
I'm saying shit, I'm gonna run away, shit.
I ain't fixing to sit here with this one.
I'm gonna just get up outta here.
And she said, "Stacy, come here."
I say, "Huh?"
"Where Dwayne at?"
"He's upstairs, I think."
Boy, I seen her go in
that room and everything.
She looking for the worsest
thing to whip us with.
It was the extension cord, man.
I'm looking her, oh, Lord, ooh.
I gotta get outta here.
I fixing to run away.
It's tough now.
That's why I say her boyfriends,
I don't be wanting to
mess with them niggas.
You know, Dwayne did that, boy.
And then one last time, though, I remember
I took my mother's boyfriend's key
and I jumped in the nigga Cadillac.
I say, shit, this motherfucker cool.
And so I was trying
to drove the Cadillac
like, I figured, you know,
you see peoples, you know, driving
with no hands and shit and
I let the steering wheel go
and that motherfucker, man
that car went woo, woo, woo.
I couldn't catch it.
Oh, man that motherfucker was wrecked.
Oh, man, I'm really in trouble now.
I don't even know how to tell Leroy.
I wrecked that car, man.
Aw, man.
I left the keys, oh.
I'm just gonna say somebody
broke in our house.
I was upstairs.
Shit, I ain't gonna know nothing.
I don't know shit.
You know what my mother say, Holmes?
"Y'all see Stone key?"
"Nuh-huh.
We fixing to go to school, Mama."
"All right, boy, I'll see y'all."
Shit, I got up outta there.
But when he seen me later,
he said, "Boy if I catch one of you niggas
ever touching my motherfucking,
I'm gonna kill you niggas.
I'm like, "Shit, man, we don't
mess with your stuff, man.
Shoot.
Probably one of Mama's old boyfriends
came in here and got your stuff, shit.
That's what you need to be checking them."
"Uh-huh.
I betcha it was your ass."
"Shit, I ain't never gonna
jump in your car, shit."
So, I mean, I had some cool times, man,
but I had some bad times, man,
because the wrong I was doing, man.
I remember one time, one
time I had a little .22, man.
It was two white dudes.
First time I ever seen this man,
two white dudes.
I thought they was the
police, though, to be honest.
They pulled in the parking lot.
I looked at them.
I say, "What's up, buddy?
What y'all want?"
They said, "We sitting here."
I say, "Y'all cops?"
They wasn't answering.
And believe me or not,
I walked to the car and I asked them,
"What y'all trying to buy,
y'all trying to buy
some drugs or something?
We know y'all cops."
They say, "We not cops."
I shit you not,
they got out the car, man.
This is the neighborhood I live in.
It's nothing but blacks at the time, man.
This is during the 70s.
It's nothing but blacks right here, dawg.
And they got out the car
and I pointed the gun at them.
I say, "Man, I could kill
y'all motherfucking asses,
fuck y'all doing?"
And man, he did the gun like this, man,
he just pushed the gun straight up
out of the face of him.
I say, "Man, what the fuck you doing?
I'll fucking kill you, dude.
Don't be putting no hands on my gun."
I say, "Y'all some crazy white boys, man.
I never seen no woods come
over here like that, man.
Y'all ain't cops?"
And they wasn't cops.
We actually didn't even
fuck with them after that.
They didn't show no
fear like they was cool.
We went on just said,
"Fuck it," and left them.
We just got on.
I was surprised because I never had a guy
take the, you know, smack the gun out
of his face, you know.
Usually, I would've boom, you know,
but I wasn't anxious to really shoot him
because it was early in the morning
and we was just thinking
the police was trying to do a little sting
and sneak in here.
But they wasn't cops.
And I'm glad that they wasn't because
he probably coulda took the gun
and killed me with the motherfucker.
But, that's the first time I ever seen
two white dudes stay down like that.
And I always remember that.